let's see if texas congressman dan
crenshaw who's got a brand new kids book
out called fame blame and the raft of
shame congressman is it possible to
mandate the whole country watch fox and
friends
that'd be interesting right
i don't think so i don't think so i
don't think i can do that for you
because you're in the minority you guys
are doing just fine right we are doing
okay we are number one already so we're
fine what do you make of all these
shortages i mean we're talking we're
hearing you need to buy your christmas
presents now christmas tree shortages
we know bacon is up 17
beef is up more than 12 percent fish
seafood eggs poultry everything's
through the roof now
gasoline prices
yeah americans are struggling on this
it's probably why you should go buy fame
blame and the raft of shame because it
is produced and shipped right here in
america um
but seriously it's yeah you like that
plug
um but but seriously this is this has
been a long time problem now and it's
for a variety of reasons so it's hard to
it's hard to narrow down exactly what we
should do about it it's a labor
shortages domestically there's not
enough truck drivers to get some of
these goods off of the cargo ships
it's covid restrictions and protocols
that slow down the entire process and
create these bottlenecks that are ports
and everybody's feeling it and it just
compounds that the supply chain issues
they compound one after another and
whatever business you're in you can't
seem to get what you need
nor can you find workers so you know
what what can we do domestically what we
should be encouraging the bite
administration to do
uh is really the opposite of what
they're doing i mean they should be
doing pro-growth policies that encourage
more hiring if we're going to
incentivize anything it shouldn't be
incentivizing workers to stay at home it
should be incentivizing them to come
back to work sure okay republicans have
been putting that forth that kind of
legislation for just about a year and a
half now whether that's like work
bonuses or whatever it might be dan is
this a big enough deal i had a ceo just
write me now and just say this is so
important to unload the ships and drive
the trucks is it enough to mobilize the
military to do it after all when you
talk about prices and goods and you talk
about shortages isn't this a national
emergency
yeah it's an interesting take i i i'm
not sure what would be involved in that
even if that would help it it's not as
if that would drive trust
yeah possibly yeah possibly but it's
like we have to be thinking of creative
ideas like that to to be perfectly
honest um you know we this is this is
what happens when when republicans
haven't been in charge for a couple
years able to pass common sense
legislation we've been trying to pass
legislation for instance that
streamlines the process for getting
qualified truck drivers on the road at
all but of course you could you could
pass that right now it doesn't
necessarily flip a switch and you have
10 000 truck drivers so you know what
you're right national guard folks that a
lot of them are qualified to drive
trucks that's an interest it's an
interesting point to make um and when
our economy needs to recover wants to
recover
but can't because it's constricted by
these factors then yeah you've got to
take some action well and i i think your
point earlier when you were talking
about your new book that we're going to
talk about in a minute is it's made in
america and unfortunately this country
has become dependent on stuff that's
made someplace else and then when covet
hit everything shut down it's taken so
long to get back up to speed because
they didn't anticipate the demand it's
all supply and demand
yeah that's exactly right um
you know a lot of places shut down
production fell through the floor and uh
and then people you know a few weeks
later said look we want to buy things
whether it's online or whether going out
to the retail stores and um that surge
in demand caused this dramatically it's
also causing a
dramatically for energy prices and
you're seeing that around the world
especially in places like europe that
have that have been implementing their
own version of a green new deal for
quite a while now they simply don't have
the capacity to deal with an upcoming
winter so they're another they're
they're importing more coal they're
importing more russian gas china is
doing the same is
vastly ramping up their coal production
and uh keep saying this over and over
again what we should be doing is
exporting our u.s natural gas which is
extremely plentiful to the rest of these
countries instead what does this
administration do attacks our oil and
gas companies and tells opec
to turn up the heat i mean it's it's
ridiculous
your governor greg abbott is banning any
entity from enforcing a cova 19 vaccine
mandate what's your reaction to that and
what are the folks in texas saying
look i i hate that we have to play this
game right this isn't the right way to
govern go to go from mandate to mandate
against a mandate it's not the right way
to govern i i still generally believe in
this whole freedom of association
principle where you can associate with
people you want to associate with as an
employer as an employee but here's the
thing the federal government already
took that first step and they're still
in the process of writing the rule under
osha that would require businesses to
vaccinate their their employees or have
them fired right this is an absurd rule
this is such an overreach it's
unconstitutional and so these reactions
you're seeing from the states are well
their reaction to that overstep in the
first place and governor abbott did what
he had to do in order to protect texas
businesses i mean this is already even
though the rule has not technically been
implemented yet
it will have it already has a chilling
effect on businesses a lot of the a lot
of ceos who you know they're either woke
or they're or they're so risk-averse
that it's pathological they immediately
implement this kind of stuff and you
know what people are fighting back we've
all been seeing what's going on with
southwest people are fighting back they
don't want to be told what to do they
know it's not practical they know it's
not necessary a lot of these people are
have natural immunity you know if you're
a pilot you're sitting away from
everybody it's not like you're in a
crowded area i mean it's just we just
don't need to be doing this and then
here's the other thing look at the tone
look at the tone of the uniter you know
just vilifying unvaccinated people as
just to the dregs of the earth not even
bringing up that 36 states have a
decrease in the delta virus and like
israel in the uk it's fallen off a cliff
instead of trying to turn the corner
he's trying to get his ratings up by
vilifying the unvaccinated here's one of
them sean walker an airline pilot who
says you can fire me because i'm not
getting it listen
heard from fellow pilots all over uh
from all airlines and it's a lot of us
are facing the same situation but this
goes far beyond the pilots because it's
not just airline pilots sure there's
airline pilots speaking out and you're
seeing it kind of in the forefront of
news but it's the flight attendants it's
the ground personnel it's everyone who
works for these major airline
corporations my health and and my
medical choices is
more important to me
than
my career at this point and i believe
standing up for this and all the
americans who feel the same way as i do
is my career is a small sacrifice
dan his wife's a pilot too so both of
them because they're not going to get
vaccinated by november 24th they're both
going to be out of work he talked to
some other pilots and one guy said was a
single dad and he's worried about
feeding his family
you know what's what's infuriating about
all this um is
we already have a shortage of pilots as
well we have you know we it's hard to
recruit people in the military because
you're seeing an exodus from the
military as well people just willing to
throw away their careers because they
don't want to take the vaccine
uh now the military is obviously a
little different than a private
organization but but the same problem
keeps bubbling up
why are we doing this you know it it's
it just because you can do it doesn't
mean you should
and we're at a point now where well over
70 percent of the country is vaccinated
and then if you add in a natural
immunity to that there's a very high
percentage of the country that that is
protected um to a pretty high extent
from this disease we can call it good
we've already seen the down drop we we
know that in
in
based on the experience of the past two
years you're going to see these spikes
every once in a while now we're probably
closer to the end of that and this
starts to look a lot more like the flu
we can stop panicking we can stop
forcing people to deal with it the way
we'd like them to deal with it because
it makes us feel better you know it's
time to start looking at the science and
what works and what doesn't and and and
accept what we cannot change as well and
stop forcing people into positions they
don't want to be in well let's see what
they do um i see the houston uh
skyscape behind you the skyline uh down
in texas uh the fox drone team took a
shot dan of about a hundred million
dollars worth of the border wall and
border wall supplies
that they simply they simply are not
gonna use it's just gonna stay there and
tell who knows what happens a texas wind
blows it away till we get a republican
president this is just one of the
reasons why people hate washington you
are calling
for the impeachment of the secretary of
homeland security my orcas after
canceling this explain more
so yeah
and i i i don't just say that you know i
i don't um i don't use that term loosely
i don't think it's uh i don't think it's
a good thing to do i think some people
just scream impeachment every time a
politician does something they don't
like
uh i'm not doing that here i think
there's very clear examples of a
deliberate dereliction of constitutional
duty uh on the part of the secretary of
homeland
security it's not just i just can't
to protect this country it's a and it
actually it has very little to do with
the cancellation of of the border wall
contracts i think that's infuriating
but but the real dereliction of duty is
simply refusal to actually enforce the
laws of our country those laws might be
our asylum process laws those laws might
be internal enforcement inside where
deportations are necessary necessary
those laws might be simply crossing the
border illegally and the only action
that dhs has taken has been against
those border agents trying to do their
job on horseback trying to stop people
from rushing the border
so it's this is very deliberate and see
intent matters when you're accusing
somebody of of what is effectively a
crime and in this case i think he
deserves impeachment absolutely he knows
better uh now the president united
states is going to have a virtual g20
and today discuss coordination uh you
shouldn't even use that word with
afghanistan but coordination on
afghanistan uh the taliban by the way
added to us that they will not do
anything to stop isis or al-qaeda but we
are agreeing to give humanitarian
assistance i would like total
transparency on that
what is your take if he doesn't get an
earful from the nato who was left out in
the cold in the g20
i don't know when would they will they
should they're probably gonna i'll let
him have it i imagine
well i would hope so i think the rest of
the world is frustrated with how
uh biden pulled out of afghanistan and
left us with this with this mess which
look you're going to continue to hear
horror stories coming out of afghanistan
whether it's girls schools closing girls
being kidnapped
public hangings
the economy completely crashing all of
it i mean none of this was done
responsibly
i'd be interested to see what kind of
humanitarian aid the g20 comes up with
but look we can't trust the taliban
they won't work with us on any
counterterrorism they've said that
multiple times they said we'll take care
of it ourselves they'll take care of
isis now they may not like isis because
they have issues with them internally
but they certainly like al qaeda
and there's no reason to think that
they're ever going to stop al-qaeda and
in fact intel shows that al qaeda
is back on track to um to grow and to
and to reconstitute so this is uh this
is a problem of epic scale congressman
tell us about your new book the
children's book
sure so look we look at this problem
where kids are exposed to plenty of
children's books that are woke and
progressive
often as we're seeing all over the
country uh schools are infusing crt
within their curriculum they they hide
it under the guise of diversity and
inclusion it's time for conservatives to
have an answer to that it's time for
conservative parents to be able to pick
from a from a set of tools and provide
that to their child so it partnered with
brave books and you can go to
bravebooks.com to get this it's the only
place you can get it by the way you
can't get it on amazon it's
bravebooks.com
and you can get my book it's the most
recent in in what's going to be a long
saga a saga that centers itself around
this place called freedom island with
the same characters a lot of the same
locations when you get this book the
kids get a big map of freedom island and
it's very interactive you'll get a
mission you'll get a cool envelope
there's games to play with your parents
and the back of the book to really to
really hammer in the lessons that we're
trying to teach and mine as you can
imagine might be about cancel culture so
my book is about cancer culture how to
overcome it how to forgive and and what
cancer culture is and what it isn't you
know because these are nuanced
conversations and we distill that into a
fun story uh that kids can relate to
well it sounds like you put a lot of
work into it uh for folks uh who would
like to get it it's at bravebooks.com
it's called fame blame and the raft of
shame he's a rhymer
congressman thank you very much let me
ask you one quick question what age
group
oh geez
young
definitely definitely for younger kids
um you know probably under eight but
okay
all right yeah all right i'll go buy it
all right good uh thanks dan appreciate
it thanks all right dan crenshaw
although i bet a lot of kids over eight
would probably like it too right let's
get through stuff like that well parents
do want to know how to talk to their
kids about these topics and so we better
get hand the book and go
tell me if you have any questions well
you don't want to you don't want to
scare the kids
just saying